There was a fascinating moment on propaganda
network, Fox News over the weekend.
If you've watched this program before, uh,
and if you haven't and you're on our youtube
channel for the first time, please make sure
you are subscribing to the channel.
We're trying to get to 1 million subscribers,
but if you've watched before, you know that
sometimes Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace will
make at least like a little sense on Fox News
and they'll cut short or short circuit, some
obvious lie here or there.
And it's a good thing when they do it.
And I have an example for you today, but this
is more than just sort of conflict porn, which
is what a lot of corporate media likes to
do.
Here's what I want you to understand about
what I'm going to play for you today.
The Trump administration and the people around
Trump are telling lies all the time about
just basic, knowable facts.
These are not lies hidden in political rhetoric
or selective statistics.
These are just straight up demonstrably lies.
And in the clip I'm going to play for you
today, Donald Trump's chief of staff, Mick
Mulvaney went on Fox News Sunday.
He was interviewed by a Fox, is Chris Wallace,
and Mulvaney tried to assert, he claimed that
Muller's testimony effectively is an exoneration
of Donald Trump.
Remember they've been claiming that Mueller's
report is an exoneration of Donald Trump,
which it's not, and now they are claiming
that Robert Mueller's testimonies and exoneration
of Donald Trump, which it's not, and they
get into a back and forth about, oh, Mueller
said there was no way Trump was getting indicted
no matter what for what he did.
This is an exoneration de facto, and in a
lot of places, Donald Trump's cronies, the
people around him, the Brown nosing sycophants
as I like to call them, they've been getting
away with this stuff.
And even on Fox News, they usually get away
with these types of lies.
It goes on challenged and then it becomes
part of the defacto status quo narrative.
This is how propaganda works.
Fox News doesn't have to perpetuate the propaganda
themselves, even though they do in many cases,
they can simply stand aside while the Trump
administration creates it.
This is why I believe in responsible platforming.
This is why when I interview an extremist,
like whoever, as many, many times I've done
before, uh, I don't have to agree with what
they say.
I can make the problem worse merely by standing
aside and letting them say their thing, which
is why I don't do that when I do interviews
with radicals and extremists.
That's why this is so important.
This is a small victory that Chris Wallace
short-circuits this.
Let's take a look at the video.
Muller answered the single one outstanding
question.
He said what?
They asked him, would you have indicted the
president if you are not the president?
And, and a Mueller said, absolutely not.
He would not do that.
He, uh, answered indirectly.
That's not what he said.
He did know that isn't what he said.
He said we didn't because of the OLC.
The office of legal counsel guidelines.
He said we could, we didn't even make a decision
on that.
You gotta ask the question by Congressman
Lou, who I know, he said, would you indicted
him if you are not the president?
And the 80 said yes, we would have.
And he went back to the beginning of the second
hearing and the added and then that's when
he said, he said, yes he did.
I agreed.
But what he said was that we, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have made it.
We didn't even make that decision because
the guidelines prevented us from doing that.
I actually just think you're wrong on that.
If they could, the record will show what a
child, if they had promised you and your role.
So
Mulvaney wants to pair it.
This idea that molar vindicated Donald Trump,
even though the opposite was actually said
at the hearing.
So let's look at the transcript of Jerry Nadler.
During the hearing said, so the report did
not conclude that he did not commit obstruction
of justice.
Is that correct?
Mueller says that is correct.
And Adler adds.
And what about total exoneration?
Did you actually totally exonerate the president
relevant because that's what Trump has been
claiming.
Molar says no Natalie or ads.
Now, in fact, your report expressly states
that it does not exonerate the president and
molar confirms it does too.
Which Natalie or ads and your investigation
actually found quote multiple acts by the
president that were capable of exerting undue
influence over law enforcement investigations,
including the Russian interference and obstruction
investigations.
Is that correct too?
Which Mueller says, correct.
This is why we have to interrupt the echo
chamber at any point where we have an opportunity
to do that because this is how propaganda
spreads.
Now, uh, when we talk about Donald Trump,
uh, and the way in which he uses Twitter,
a lot of his Twitter use, a more interesting
analysis of his Twitter use I will say is
not about the content of each tweet per se,
but about the way in which Donald Trump will
use Twitter to start tweeting the exact same
stuff that his chief of staff will go on Fox
News and say, and that then some right wing,
uh, activist, uh, commentator we'll do a blog
post about, and Donald Trump jr will retweet
this is how they foam at that ACA echo chamber.
The way that the propaganda machine works
is obfuscate and mischaracterize as much as
you can.
I call that line.
You could use those softer terms obfuscate
and ms character characterize if you want,
in order to make the truth very difficult
to even find because you're waiting through
all sorts of conflicting statements.
Then once you've inserted your narrative into
the broader discussion, which is there's nothing
to see here, you start to miss direct and
distract with things like Baltimore is infested
as an example.
And then in other cases, you simply say nothing
altogether.
You go totally silent as if the issue not
exists, doesn't exist, which is actually a
really effective way to short circuit the
media narrative because if media can't get
people to react to something, it becomes very
difficult to continue that story on and on
and on.
That's the broader way in which the propaganda
model works.
And Chris Wallace, I mean, listen, I'm not
going to go around telling you Chris Wallace
is the best person around, but to the extent
that he at least short-circuited this one
minor element of Donald Trump's cronies trying
to spread propaganda lies, I think better
said, uh, we should commend him for it.
Make sure that you are following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman show,
and while you're there, follow me as well.
At David Dot Pacman, I've finally got, finally,
I've got a tomato plant.
I've been monitoring and watering
and pruning for three months and I finally
got some tomatoes.
There's a picture on my Instagram.
Go
check
it out.